hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde es ist allseits bekannt dass ich
absolut keine gehirnzellen
einfach nur perfekt dass ich heute mal
wieder ein quiz video hochladen also
erste frage welches hier ist am größten
der löwe
hier wird gefragt wie man die blumen
erblühen lassen kann nicht einfach mal
auf die wolkendecke
den elefanten in den kühlschrank okay
wenn mir
das auch zu einfach und daher stehen wir
ihnen fanden erst mal der weg machen
irgendwie die tür auf nee das geht nicht
kann ich den hier drauf nicht darunter
jeder kann ich
was ist uns näher die sonne oder dämme
und die sonne ist falsch
[Applaus]
ich finde es ein bisschen komisch wie
viele pizzastücke sind hier zu finden
wir haben ein zwei drei vier fünf falsch
43 21
50 falsch 6
neben gebracht
warum waren da eher zehn ich habe
diverse kostenlose probe abo kündigen
der gare perfekt uhr ich habe den
rennfahrer auf dem zweiten platz
überholt welchem platz habe ich jetzt in
zweiten
diese jetzt wieder holen sich und ich
werde immer wieder aufs neue rasieren
[Musik]
ich töte euch wische nach links um den
bildschirm zu entsperren
das ist schon
bitter füttere die katze sie hat hunger
die katze können wir nicht hochziehen
die kekse können wir auch nicht
runterziehen können wir den
stacheldrahtzaun wegmachen nee nee ich
kann die kann und nicht auf die katze
klicken kann ich den zaun irgendwie wenn
ich schreibe ich die kekse zerbröseln
draufklicken die kekse doll schneider
ich habe keine ahnung
das wort katze zählt ebenfalls mau ihr
habt echt keine ideen
ich kündige
wo ist die grüne kugel okay wir haben
nur rot blau gelb kann ich irgendwas
verzieren erklärte guck mal ich
denke schon so wohl wie die welcher
monat ist am längsten märz februar bei
der mine
der februar
wähler eine bonus belohnung muss ich mir
sagt wie ein video und gucken fange fünf
einfach so
hier die ach so ich muss fallende äpfel
fangen
hey das ist doch echt nicht war die
katze muss auf die andere seite springen
da nehmen wir die katze können wir nicht
wir haben
[Musik]
das wiso anderen sportunterricht
wie wärs wenn ich springen gedrückt
halte und dann haus lasse ich auch nicht
wenn man doppelsprung machen
damit die katze irgendwie hier schon
klicken kann mir das irgendwie vorziehen
sondern bis zum springen und dann nie
was ist wenn ich das handy anlass um
halte
perfekt geht auch nichts mit dem pilz
[Musik]
klar wir können alle von pilzen kann man
weiter springen wir sollen hier den
wasserkocher aus kochen sonst kocht er
noch über aber ist dass sein alter
und warum lag der sich dieses scheint
angebot 44 plus 5 x 5 - 2 punkt
verstrich richtungen also 55 erst
bereiche sind 25 plus 4 sind 29 also 27
mit intelligenz werde ich meistertitel
in der reihenfolge auf die zahlen eins
bis
jetzt nicht einfach weg aber ich habe
wohl grafisches gedächtnis nächstes 11
49 780 101 und 5
ich wusste dass meine eltern mich
angelogen haben wie lautet die
versteckte zahl 5 - 5
ach so das ist kein - das ist eine
reihenfolge b5 plus 10 nochmal +10 doch
keinen sinn
ein paar sekunden später
so
wie viele monate haben 28 tage
eigentlich würde ich sagen einer weil
nur der februar kann manchmal 28 tage
haben aber jeder monat 28 tage
um die ecke denken viele denken
wenn alle auf zeit wurden den bogen
denken denken zeit von den box
bitte hier ist dem jungen der heutige
sie die ganze zeit voll wir haben eine
schaufel wenn wir die auf den hund ich
mich schlagen das geht nicht immer die
shoa wie konstruiert und die knochen
spiel das spiel deutlich wo steckt das
schwarze schaf natürlich hinter
irgendeinem schlafen kann ich jedoch
aufnehmen kann ja und ich kann ich hier
nicht gar nicht nur nicht wenn ich
habe jetzt das wort stark auf dem scharf
gezogen hat das schwarze wolle das ist
wirklich ich höre ich kotz dem besitzer
einfach an wenn nicht im demnächst
treffen sollte keine ahnung wo ich ihn
treffen sollte aber wenn ich ihn treffen
sollten auf jeden fall nicht an lager
zum maul womit endet das alphabet mit
dem ach so es geht safe um das wort
alphabet t
noch eine zukunft in dieser woche auf
unserer katzen party gibt es einen
ungeladenen gast okay wir haben irgendwo
auch da kommt es einem aus
ich bin auch eine kleine maus mich
damals rettete sie sie schreibt auch die
ganze zeit setzte auf gehört zum glück
okay wir haben hier eine katze die
können wir in den mülleimer schmeißen
wir können mit einmal auf sie packen rat
kommt man sieht aus dieser mit dem hut
wir haben hier steine
hier haben wir was wolken geht
an einem herzinfarkt bekommen weil das
so laut waren nie mehr aus okay
das ist der easy
recht nicht
anders geht
ich schwöre euch ich bin so stolz auf
dieses video weil ich es einfach endlich
mal hinkriege etwas zu schaffen macht
dass sie sich verlieben okay der junge
schläft das mädel schild hier ich könnte
einen luftballon geben
luftballon an die ring ihren luftballon
hier dran ist irgendwas drin nicht inkl
ich fühle mich ganz so wie mathe
unterricht wenn man angenommen wurde und
man wollte eigentlich gar nicht ran
genommen werden man hat sich einfach nur
so gemeldet weil sich auch genügend
andere gemeldet haben dann wollte man
zeigen ich weiß es auch und wenn man
dann daran genommen wurde dann wenn man
auf
und dann habe ich immer was geraten und
ich fühle mich gerade so als wenn das
was sich dann geraten hätte richtig
gewesen wäre und genau aus diesem grund
würde ich das heutige video an der
stelle jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat wie
ich brennt es gespielt habe dann lasst
doch gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video abonnenten den kanal und klickt
auf die glocken weitere videos nicht zu
verpassen ich bin aktuell im urlaub das
heißt ihr könnt ihr auch gerne auf
instagram folgen denn dann seht ihr was
ich da so mache zum beispiel am strand
schießen bekommen weil ich schlecht in
fußball bin ja vielleicht sollten wir
doch nicht auf dienstag folgen